hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
illinit eh Q Sigma metrics presented by
Sten Westgard director of client
services and Technology Westgard quality
control and Cristie jewel of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminars
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by Abbott Laboratories for more
information on our sponsor please visit
core laboratory dot Abbott now let's get
started I would like to remind everyone
that today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just use that
ask a question box and let us know
you're experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and the
software's continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab and follow the process to
obtain your credit
I'd now like to introduce today's
presenters Stan Westgard Stan Westgard
is a director of client services and
technology for Westgard quality control
he earned his MS degree in theater
science from Pace University in New York
for more than 20 years stan has managed
the Westgard website chorus portal blog
creating and administering online
training as well as editing and writing
hundreds of reports essays and
applications on quality control method
validation Six Sigma risk management in
other laboratory management topics for a
complete biography on stem please visit
the biography tab sten you may now begin
your presentation
you
thank you very much Christy for that
kind introduction and welcome all of you
to this webinar on designing quality
control for hematology instrumentation
that has to do with Sigma metrics so
it's a we're going to be covering some
basic things and also some advanced
things and basic QC challenges that have
been with us since we started running QC
for hematology as well as some of the
latest tools and techniques for
optimizing how we run that QC and I want
to start with a disclosure statement I
just want to be very open
Abid diagnostics is compensating me for
my time and we couldn't have this
webinar today without their support
there is however a much more important
disclosure that I do need to make and
that is particularly important when
you're listening to this as a webinar
and you can't see me if you didn't see
me you didn't know any better you might
be thinking that I'm the Westgard the
one who came up with the Westgard rules
but actually I am really only a Westgard
I am the son of James Westgard
James Westgard of course is the author
of the Westgard rules and really has
spent more than half a century working
in quality control for laboratories I am
the junior employee I've been only doing
this for about a quarter of a century
when I'm not doing webinars or lectures
or workshops or any kind of training
we're running the Westgard website so we
have a number of different resources and
a good deal of it is free this will be a
good resource for you following the
webinar to explore some of the things
that we'll we'll talk about briefly in
this broadcast
so our first website is our main
flagship
Westgard comm has more than 65,000
laboratory professional members in more
than 600 different articles on Westgard
rules and QC and all kinds of topics
related to quality and analytical
performance in the center you see our
course portal which is where we do
structured training if you need
continuing education or contact hours we
have courses and Westgard rules and QC
and sigma metrics and then in the lower
right you see what we call a blog this
is where we handle shorter articles
comments things about what's going on in
the news and probably most importantly
of all we handle our questions and
answers there so as you can imagine
there are a lot of questions coming in
we like to answer them so that we not
only help the lab that has the courage
to ask for help but also dozens of other
labs that really are facing the same
problems but may not realize that
they're not alone all of this material
on Westgard dot-com and the blog that's
all free so there's a lot of free
resources for you and we'll be going
through now some of the specific tools
that are good for hematology but before
we delve into those I want to step back
and
really focus us on why we're talking
about quality still and why we we must
continue to talk about quality we cannot
just assume that because a manufacturer
has a good marketing campaign and they
assert that they have great quality that
therefore we don't have to do our jobs
and we have no professional
responsibility what you see in front of
you of course is a picture of the
now-infamous ther knows and its founder
Elizabeth owns a company that took in
almost a billion dollars of funding and
promptly destroyed all of it because at
heart it was an instrument that had no
quality they could not produce reliable
results and one of the people who helped
bring this fraud down was a medical
technologist her name was Erica Cheung
you can see her in this documentary from
HBO and I had the pleasure of
communicating with her she was saying
that one of the reasons why she felt bad
about what her company was doing is she
was looking at the Westgard rules she
was learning about QC and she quickly
realized that what was happening at this
company
was not following the basic of QC
principles and practices they weren't
implementing Westgard rules and if the
quote says they were very far from Six
Sigma laboratory principles and based on
understanding that that gave Erika the
the consonant and really a the mission
to say I can't let this these kinds of
results go out the door I have to
protect patients and she helped blow the
whistle and then the inspectors came in
and shut that laboratory down which
ultimately led to that company ceasing
to exist going completely bankrupt and
that's one of the things that we can get
out of proper QC and these Six Sigma
principles they can tell us when we're
not doing our job and when we have in
particular an instrument that is not
providing the quality that's necessary
for patient care
you
talking about the problems of QC
specifically in hematology we're going
to talk also about Westgard rules and
Six Sigma and even a more advanced topic
the optimization of QC frequency this is
really the next generation of how we're
going to do QC not just in hematology
but really on any instrument we're going
to figure out how many Westgard rules
are necessary how good is this assay on
the six sigma scale and when we know
that Sigma metric it will change the
rules it will change the controls we
have to run and it will change how often
we have to run those controls and we'll
look at a couple examples of real word
instruments and performance and apply
those tools so you can see how this will
work for your hematology tests
so let's review a little bit about our
problems specifically in hematology what
you see is a paper from 2010 so this is
a little bit of a while back but here is
the sort of paradox that we find
ourselves in hematology and then people
assume the instruments themselves are
quite good but then there's a high
amount of variability in how QC is
practiced and a lot of practices that
are not considered ideal so in some
recent surveys we've seen a 12 full
variation in QC some recent surveys have
shown that you know here in the US some
of the leading academic medical centers
some labs are doing QC once a day and
other labs are doing QC twelve times a
day a 12 fold difference that's telling
us that the practice of QC is not very
standardized even in some of the best
institutions in America and that means
we really need to bring better tools and
assessments into how we practice our QC
one of the frequently asked questions
about hematology QC is whether they can
just rely on the manufacturer's
information and if the manufacturer says
this is the mean and this is a standard
deviation you don't have to figure it
out yourself
you just use their information if we
look at the global quality standard of
ISO n15 189 it says very clearly you
have to design internal QC systems that
verify the attainment of the intended
quality results in that that language
implies that you're doing your own
calculations you're not going to simply
rely on the manufacturer
also we're not supposed to rely just on
manufacturer provided controls again the
global standard for quality and its most
recent edition recommends that
third-party independent controls should
be used to monitor your processes if the
manufacturer has its own control they're
not considered as reliable it's too
often known and many of you know the
anecdotal evidence that manufacturer
controls and ranges can sometimes be
tweaked or adjusted they might
synchronize a control to a new reagent
lot and you lose the objective
independence the ability to truly
monitor what's going on with that
instrument you may miss some of your
errors
and with hematology it's very tempting
to just use the manufacturers control
range but the CSI guideline which states
the best practices for hematology QA and
QC it says that the laboratory must
establish its own expected mean and QC
values of recovered control values and
it specifically calls out the published
manufacturer ranges they are too broad
for effective QC if you rely on someone
else's range the manufacturer ranges are
typically built on many many labs and so
there's more variation and those ranges
are much bigger and if you use them you
may feel like everything's in control
but really what's happening is there may
be errors occurring that are going
through that very broad range and going
out and reaching patients you are being
blinded to them because you've set up
your chart so that you don't see those
important errors you're not catching
them
you
you
the other thing that we have with QC for
hematology and this is in particular
something that because of the lifespan
of hematology controls
it comes up
that labs feel the lot the the control
doesn't last long enough to really
establish the own their own mean and
standard deviation and if you collect
the minimum recommendation of 20 data
points you may uh you know if you're
only running QC once a day then that's
almost a month and you may only have one
more month or at most two more months on
that control lot so it's it seems it
feels like it's a lot of extra effort to
keep up with establishing your own mean
and your own variation and there are a
couple different solutions some are
better than others probably the least
effort is overlap your controls between
the new lot and a lot by a short period
of time making multiple measurements
you'll be able to establish a new mean
you'll get a new SD but downside is that
over a short period of time that SD is
not as reliable it probably will be
overly optimistic so these other
solutions are what we would prefer the
second one is to use eight or more
overlap values to establish your new
mean and with just a few number of
measurements you can effectively
establish the new mean it's the new
standard deviation that really needs
more data and so while you're waiting to
collect enough data for the new standard
deviation you could use the old CV from
the previous lot of controls and then
you multiply that by the new mean and
that will give you a temporary St so
you'll have a temporary SD to cover sort
of the first 20 data points while you're
trying to collect enough information to
establish the real standard deviation of
that new control lot so you have some
sort of temporary crutch to lean on
while you're developing more information
the third solution and this is one that
takes into account much more data in
over a longer period of time is to use
multiple Lots
so you have a cumulative mean you have a
cumulative SD you put together three to
six months worth of performance data now
that relies on an assumption that from
control lot to control lot there's a lot
of stability and consistent performance
if you find the controls do not have
that that lots a lot there's big jumps
in big changes in SD that's not going to
be a good solution but solution three is
really the one that we would like
laboratories to adopt for Hematology QC
and now we're ready to look at
Six Sigma concepts this is the solution
to all of those previous problems that
we were just talking about Six Sigma is
a universally accepted way to benchmark
your quality and it came out of
manufacturing in industry it's also used
in lots of other phases of healthcare
we're particularly lucky in laboratories
to be able to take advantage of Six
Sigma because we collect all the data
that is necessary to do a sigma metric
and the idea what Six Sigma is you're
going to convert your measurement you
through a calculation into a something
on the scale from zero to six and when
you're at Six Sigma you have less than
four defects per million reportable
results so it's really almost defect
free and that means you're going to have
clinicians who are very confident in the
analytical quality they don't feel like
they need to run the test over and over
to figure out what's going on with the
patient your first result is going to be
the right result and at Six Sigma when
the originators of this this technique
achieved it so we go back to several
decades to companies like General
Electric and Motorola when they found
they were at Six Sigma
they had extremely happy customers
because they were getting the right
process the right output and they were
getting it reliably and they had they
had good confidence so it's great on the
customer side but internally they also
found well there's a lot less effort we
have to make we're not making mistakes
we're not having to come up with
workarounds we're not having to do work
over and over again so it's also very
efficient and very profitable for them
GE and Motorola they found that 3 Sigma
was about the floor on performance for
them below 3 Sigma which is something
more than about 67,000 defects per
million results reportable results that
becomes too unstable
there's too many errors you're going to
spend too much of your time having to
fix those errors and come up with
workarounds and do extra effort it
becomes too expensive to really to keep
that process as a routine part of your
business and within healthcare if we
look at our laboratory below 3 Sigma is
really where we start to see labs and
tests that are going to be repeating
their controls frequently and
recalibrating a lot of the time and
and troubleshooting multiple times in a
month and calling up their technical
support and and really it's just a lot
of extra activity a lot of burden that a
laboratory has to shoulder when they
have a test that is so low in quality
there are a lot of different quality
requirements that are available for
hematology and this is the first part of
establishing a sigma metric is to really
establish what is the performance
required by the method what is the
quality goal if you will and we have
CLIA in the United States as having set
a bunch of allowable total errors in
Germany there's the really Bach there is
a biological variation database that was
started by Carmen Rico's in Spain and
that database terminated in about 2014
but that's probably the most popular
global set of quality requirements for
hematology
there's also from the Spanish
proficiency testing programs a consensus
on the minimum quality and then most
recently this year the European
Federation of laboratory medicine or ESL
M they have created this UV vos which is
again based on biological variation but
more in more recent information and they
have also set that up as a database
online so we have at least five
different sources of quality goals for
some of our tests and you'll notice they
don't agree
some of them disagree quite a bit
sometimes there's a goal from CLIA which
is twice as large as a goal from UV vos
so among them we try and make some
choices and typically for labs we will
ask them for the main parameters look at
the clear requirements for another for
the MCV look at the spanish consensus
and then there are other sort of the
differential counts where most of the
major EQA and proficiency testing they
do not set a specific goal so you have
to look at the biologic berry ation and
the biologic variation goals from rico's
are the ones that are at the moment the
most practical goals to achieve the new
goals that were that came out this year
we have found to be very difficult for
laboratories and instruments around the
world what you see here is a set of
performance measurements this is a bias
versus allowable bias for four different
instruments and I don't want to call out
specific instrument types I'm just going
to say these are some of them are major
instruments from major diagnostic
providers and others are smaller
instruments from smaller companies that
you may never heard of but when we look
at the desirable bias
which can come out of that European
Federation of biomedicine set of
specifications how many of these tests
can actually achieve the desirable by
having below that particular level of
bias
well across the board with these four
instruments that we looked at more than
half of all the performance in these
tests cannot meet those bias goals more
than half of the numbers being reported
at different control levels and
different parameters are failing the
desirable bias test and if you see a
goal that has come out and in the worst
case three-quarters of the performance
of one instrument cannot hit that
desirable bias it you begin to think
that set of goals may be too tight for
today's market maybe in a market place
in the future
maybe in the next generation of
instruments from some 5-10 years from
now maybe they will have a chance to hit
these new goals but right now they
appeared to be very difficult to achieve
and it's also true for the imprecision
goals so the bias goal is more than half
of them couldn't hit the bicycles
there's a quite a big spread of
performance in the precision goals so
some instruments more than 80% of their
performance cannot hit the precision
goals another instrument more than half
of it cannot fit the imprecision goals
so again those particular goals may not
be appropriate for today's for today's
performance for today's instrumentation
and there their generation of methods
take up goals we've listed on the
Westgard website what we call a
consolidated hematology set of goals you
see that screenshot is showing you the
different sources of allowable total
errors and one of the things that we
have found is that there's no one set of
goals so even CLIA doesn't give you
enough goals to cover all the different
parameters so you have to look at not
just CLIA but some other goals and we
try to identify which goals and we
recommend as most practical without
being too easy we don't want to make a
goal that everybody can hit because that
probably means it's too easy that it's
too wide so we try and find a a median
goal something that is challenging that
helps move the industry forward
once we've settled on the right goal
what we have selected these performance
specifications essentially you have to
think that is setting a target by
figuring out that allowable total error
wherever it happens to come from now you
have a target to hit with your assay
performance whether you hit that target
well that's when we start to measure our
own performance and this is where we
already have the data at hand we've been
collecting data on our analytical
performance since we open the doors of
our laboratory and what we specifically
want to collect is imprecision or CV
data as well as inaccuracy or biased
data and while typically we may be
running two or three levels of controls
we might want to focus on particular
medical decision levels and focus on the
signal metrics at one particular level
of a test rather than all three levels
we put all these three variables
together the allowable total air and the
bias and the CV in our Sigma metric
equation so this is our first tool and
it helps us benchmark the quality of our
assay on the Sigma metric scale and what
you do is you take the allowable total
air you subtract the absolute value of
the bias and then you divide by the CV
it's your performance goal - your
inaccuracy / your imprecision and then
the graphic below that is really to give
you a visual sense of how the equation
works in the center of that graphic you
see the true value that's the answer
we're supposed to be getting but of
course we don't always get that answer
we get a distribution
we get a bell curve around that true
value and then at either side of that
true value there's a allowable total
there and that that zone from allowable
total error on the left hand to the
right hand that's the amount of error we
could make with our measurement without
changing the diagnosis without changing
how the patient is treated you can keep
within your allowable total air you
won't get the exact answer but you'll
get an answer that is close enough that
the clinician makes the right diagnosis
the patient gets the right treatment so
we want to keep all of our values if
possible within that space the data that
we get from the bias and CD tells us how
much of our curve is actually in that
space the bias will tell us how far away
we've shifted from the true value and
the CD will tell us the spread of that
curve how wide the curve goes how much
dispersion there is in the results and
when you combine that bias and CV you
may see as we do on the right end of
this graphic there's a part of the tail
that goes outside the allowable total
error we have some results exceeding the
allowable total there and what that
indicates is that area under the curve
those are the defective results they may
be false positives they may be false
negatives the results that are
clinically significantly wrong
so having introduced that tool let's
walk through how that tool is working so
we'll take an example three levels of
the hemoglobin method and if we want to
know the Sigma of hemoglobin we need our
three numbers we need the allowable
total error which CLIA directly
regulates so we know we have to be good
within seven percent of the true value
and in this particular data example we
have been running three levels of
control so we have imprecisions at
different levels low and high and
somewhere maybe the normal all of them
less than one percent and then through a
comparison and Method study we've also
calculated out the bias so we have bias
using a regression equation at the same
three levels where we've figured out our
imprecision so we can actually do a
sigma metric at each level that we're
running a control and you can see at the
first level you have seven minus the
bias of 0.4 and you divide that by 0.5
we actually have a better than Six Sigma
performance and this is actually at the
I believe the high end of the range for
that test the next performance is at the
low end of the range of seven minus the
bias of three point one divided by an
imprecision of less than one or about
point eight again
that's a good good result we have a five
Sigma performance at that low end and
then in the middle we have seven minus
the bias of one point four divided by an
imprecision of 0.6 it's better than Six
Sigma at the upper end of the range so
here you see at the extreme ends of the
rain rain at the normal and the high end
we have better than six different
performance at the lower end we have
five Sigma performance and you may want
to decide how to treat this a site now
do you treat it as a Six Sigma si if you
treat it as a five Sigma si do you
average all of that and six eighths
well it's somewhere in between five and
six Sigma
and it's really up to you how you want
to do that however on hemoglobin you
want to also figure out what is the
critical decision level for hemoglobin
and use the metric that you're finding
at around that level as the way you're
going to treat the hemoglobin method
there's the data if you're just looking
at how things were calculated that's the
data set that we have for that example
calculated it you have the Sigma metric
for a particular test but you may want
to actually visualize it some of us
don't like to look at any more numbers
than they then we have to and to
introduce a whole new set of
spreadsheets and tables may may seem
like more work on an already
overburdened workload so we do try and
simplify these things
what we have now is a method decision
chart and this gives you a visual way to
figure out the Sigma metric of your
method and in fact you can adapt this so
that it you can look at all the methods
all the levels of your entire hematology
instrument and on one graph you can
figure out how you're doing so it's a
visual assessment rather than having to
do all the calculations and what you do
is you take the imprecision and that
becomes your x-axis you take the bias
that becomes your y-axis
and then you're going to plot your
imprecision and your bias as x and y
coordinates so we have a tool called the
method decision chart and the method
decision chart helps you plot and
visualize the performance of your
analytical quality you don't have to do
as many calculations you can look at
really an entire instrument worth of
performance in a single glance along the
x-axis you're going to plot your
imprecision along the bots y-axis you're
going to plot your bias so your CV and
your bias for each of your control
points those are your x and y
coordinates and the way this graph works
your diagonal lines that divide the
graph up into sigma zones near the
graphs origin you have world-class
quality that's the Six Sigma and better
performance if you have about five sigma
that's considered excellent performance
for Sigma is considered good performance
three sigma as we said earlier is the
minimum or the marginal level of quality
two sigma is poor less than two sigma is
unacceptable and if you will you can
consider this chart similar to a
bull's-eye similar to a target what you
want is to have your data as close to
the bullseye as possible the closer you
get the fewer defects you will have the
more confidence you'll have that you're
getting the right result
you have more imprecision as you have
more bias however you're getting further
away from those lines or rings of the
target which means you're generating
more defects which means you're starting
to put more analytical noise noise
around all of your results and then in
the upper-right quadrant
really you're confusing clinicians
you're making things very uncertain
you're not going to be able to really
confirm a diagnosis much more likely
that you're just going to confuse the
clinician
so having introduced that tool we're
going to walk through some examples
we're going to start with an instrument
that's a new instrument I'm not going to
call out its name but you can see by
this it's got eight assays and multiple
levels that we measured and almost all
of them are below two Sigma in fact
most of them are really off the chart I
tucked them at the edge of the graph
because I just needed to keep them
within visual range but if I let those
points go they'll probably drift off the
right of your screen and this is you
know one of the things that we have to
worry about as we see more and more new
entries and new diagnostic companies
coming to market with cheap hematology
instruments they may not be delivering
good quality whenever it's too
inexpensive you have to worry they
compromised their quality and that's how
they made a cheap instrument
you
they're instruments this is just one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven maybe different methods and a
majority of them again are below two
sigma there's a couple in the bullseye
but most of them are pretty poor in
performance and really are tucked at the
edge of the graph some of these are not
are at the top edge of the graph which
means actually the problem may not be in
precision but really it's the bias
and now here's a look at the abbot limit
e and this has 15 different assays three
levels each there's 45 levels of
performance and you will see that two
thirds you see the light blue the dark
blue and the green that's 60 more than
66 percent of the performance are at
four and five and six Sigma so you can
see there's some big variability out in
the marketplace hematology instruments
are not commodities we cannot take the
quality for granted we really have to
assess them and make sure they're
delivering the level of quality that is
necessary
next tool we want to look at is the tool
that changes how we do QC because it's
useful to have these method decision
charts and see what's in the bull's eye
and what isn't but much more useful
would be to know what do you do with the
information
if I tell you you have a Six Sigma
methodology instrument do you know what
to do for QC do you continue using all
the Westgard rules do you continue
running QC at a high frequency or can
you change those things and one of the
simplest tools that we've made available
in the last few years is what we call
Westgard Sigma rules take the
traditional Westgard rules but it adds
that Six Sigma component and what you
can see on this flowchart it's the
traditional Westgard rules when it been
slightly updated but if you look a
little bit below the red box you'll see
the indications of different Sigma's and
then there's some blue vertical lines
that are dividing the Westgard rules
into different sections so at Six Sigma
you may see
there's a blue line that's that
basically cuts off the Westgard rules
into just one rule the one 3s rule then
at five Sigma you'll see there are three
rules
three rules are necessary for a method
of five sitting at four Sigma you need
four Westgard rules at three Sigma you
need all the Westgard rules so as your
Sigma gets lower you need more Westgard
rules and below three segments remember
three Sigma being the minimum level of
quality that we think is appropriate
below three sigma the Westgard rules
can't help you you will need all the
Westgard rules but you will also need to
add non-statistical QC you'll need to do
much more additional techniques maybe
those algorithm may be more frequent
monitoring or more frequent calibration
something to do that to help keep that
method under proper monitoring and keep
it in to keep it well well observed
you
and here's a table version of that where
we've listed out
our Sigma's and the controller rules
that are necessary and the number of
controls and then on the very right
column we're looking at one of our
instrument examples and it's telling us
how much of the performance that we saw
in the previous graph was located in the
particular Sigma zones and most striking
72% of this laboratory instruments
performance is below three sigma so that
means this lab needs to use all the
Westgard rules on most you know nearly
three-quarters of the testing it needs
to use more controls themselves not just
the usual two or three but probably more
like six which if you're not able to
afford running that on a single run you
have to start looking across multiple
runs
when we look at the illinit II we can
see actually majority of that
performance is at five and six Sigma and
that's going to mean we reduce the
number of Westgard rules necessary up
for almost forty percent of the
performance we don't need the Westgard
rules at all and we can get away with a
minimum number of controls in fact
that's it's one area where we could
consider going down to two controls
rather than three levels of controls
because that three levels that may be a
tradition but statistically or
mathematically it's not necessary for a
Six Sigma test
now what we've looked at in our example
so far is changing the rules and the
number of controls being run but now
we'd like to think about changing the
frequency changing how often we have to
run QC and this has been a question that
has we've been grappling and struggling
with QC frequencies since we started
running QC in laboratories so it's not a
new question it's something we've always
had but we've had a lot of rules of
thumb the first rule of thumb being we
base our QC frequency on the rotational
speed of the planet so we're doing it
once a day or once every 24 hours
sometimes it's more frequently might be
doing it two or three times a day
once every eight hours these are not
scientific choices there are simply
rules of thumb and in the last four
years we adopted in the u.s. something
called iqcp which justified an even
stranger practice which is to reduce
your QC to once a month you're basing
your QC frequency on the lunar calendar
none of this seems to be related at all
to the patient
patience health state doesn't have to
have anything to do with the phase of
the moon nor does it have anything to do
with how fast our planet is turning we
really would like a patient based QC
frequency and that comes from adopting a
much more rigorous mathematical approach
so
chuckle approach that helps us determine
QC frequency comes from Kurt parven in a
paper that was published more than ten
years ago
it's often called the max enough model
with that max enough really standing for
the maximum number of expected final
unacceptable patient results it's
calculating how many results could be at
risk of being wrong for the patients if
we have an error that we haven't
detected with our QC it creates a bunch
of risk curves
and these risk curves are a little
exotic you've probably never seen them
before but we'll just take a quick look
at them along the x-axis is the size of
the air along the y-axis is the number
of patients we're going to be at risk of
getting a wrong result and these risk
curves all start at zero because if we
have no analytical error there are no
patients at risk I think we can all
agree about that but once a little bit
of air starts to creep into our methods
the first thing we'll discover is small
tiny errors are not really well detected
by our QC rules recusing rules can't
pick up small errors so if there's a
small error our QC rule can't pick it up
so that error is more likely to impact
patients so now we have patients who are
at risk so our risk curves are going to
start going up and they will keep going
up until the size of the air reaches a
certain a certain point certain size of
error that is finally detectable
and our QC rules really start to kick in
the air is big enough we can start
detecting and catching that air and then
that's when the risk curves start to go
down again because as the air gets
bigger than that the bigger it gets the
easier it is for our QC rule to detect
it and go off and then therefore there
are fewer patients at risk because we
detected there the result wasn't
released fewer patients are at risk and
for very large errors our QC rules catch
them right away and there's never any
risk to patients so the risk curves go
back down to zero again and the reason
why we have different risk curves is we
have different QC rules that we're using
if we have Westgard rules and we're
using for control measurements that's
actually the solid line that you see on
this particular graph if we have
Westgard rules but we're using two
controls then that's a dashed line then
you see with more controls being run we
have a smaller maximum risk we have less
than one patient that that max enough is
less than one that means there's less
than one patient who is at risk of
getting a wrong result
I'm a - line our maximum risk is close
to three patients that is there may be
at the maximum amount of risk with using
this set of rules is that up to three
patients may be hit with a medical error
that we have if we don't detect the
analytical error that's happening
the thing about knowing these Peaks
points of the graph the maximum risk is
that if we do know that we can figure
out also ways to change those variables
so we can minimize that maximum risk and
typically the goal is try and get the
maximum risk down to one or less than
one patient out of any particular run
the last few years some papers have come
out that have converted these risk
curves and the mathematical approach
into a simple visual tool so rather than
make you learn how to calculate the max
enough and plot your own risk curve what
we've done is sort of transformed that
so that you're going to like the method
decision chart you're going to have a
simple visual assessment tool and that
visual assessment tool we call the Six
Sigma QC frequency nomogram and here you
don't need to know max enough at all
along the x-axis you need to know your
Sigma metric along the y-axis that's
actually the number of patients that can
go in between your QC events
diagonal lines represent the different
QC rules that you might be using are you
using multi ruler Westgard rules with
certain numbers of controls are you
using a set of single control limits and
if you knew the segment metric which
we've already explored is not very hard
to determine you figure out that Sigma
you look up and see where it intersects
the QC rule that you're using and then
from that point you go all the way over
to the y-axis
and that'll tell you how many patients
you can go you can allow to pass before
you have to run QC again and this is
called a nomogram because it's a
logarithmic distribution the numbers get
high higher and higher very quickly at
the top end of the graph and probably
the most interesting things you want to
notice is that at Six Sigma we're off
the chart at Six Sigma the intersection
of any of those QC lines is going to
happen more than 500 patients between
our QC runs in fact it's probably going
to be at least a thousand
so that's the good news is if if we have
Six Sigma we'll be able to reduce not
only our QC rules and our numbers of
controls but will reduce our QC
frequency
the other bit of news is what happens at
the other end of this graph at the lower
left corner and that's when you have
assays below three Sigma and you can
quickly see that
if we have a below 3 Sigma si we're
going to be running QC quite frequently
Sigma assay running Westgard rules with
four controls is going to have to run
those four controls every ten patient
samples that's very frequent very very
frequent
and we can put that into a summary table
again with Six Sigma telling us
conservatively we can reduce our QC
frequency to once per 1000 patients
whereas below three Sigma we want to be
looking at once per 10 patients if
you're even lower if you're at 2 Sigma
or 1 Sigma effectively it becomes as
ridiculous as you need to run a QC for
every patient
and of course that's absurd that means
essentially we cannot we don't have
enough resource to properly QC that
method if it's both if it's a very low
Sigma not only can we not monitor it
well enough with Westgard rules but we
can't afford to run as many controls as
necessary
we've also summarized that in the
Westgard Sigma rules I didn't I didn't
take note of it in the earlier
presentation of it but you see in the
the red box at the bottom those are the
suggested run sizes for the different
Sigma zones so this particular Westgard
Sigma rules formulation that particular
chart you can download for free off the
Westgard website and it can help you
figure out your Sigma metric and figure
out your Westgard rules and figure out
how many controls to run and how often
you need to run those controls
if we now look at our two examples that
we went through for one of our methods
again which we didn't want to call out
but for this instrument X they have to
be running all the Westgard rules they
should be thinking about a dozen
controls
and be running once every 10 patients if
not more frequently that effectively
you're running more controls than you're
running patients
that's an instrument that is just not
appropriate for the lab it's a budget
buster it's not good for patients for
the illinit II will see that a majority
of the performance we will not have to
use all the Westgard rules there's no
perfect instrument
there are some areas there are some some
of the differential accounts are
particularly challenging and those will
need more Westgard rules and possibly
more controls but if you look at the
overall performance and if you have to
synchronize how you're going to do QC
you're probably going to do it on a
reduced frequency with reduced rules and
therefore reduced expenses
this up
gone over a lot of different tools per
QC and benchmarking and and performance
assessment I want to assure you that
every different tool that I've
introduced in this very short time you
can download for free off the Westgard
website and then there are more examples
of how to use those tools and more
examples of different instruments out
there so you can figure out what's out
there and how you would apply these
tools in a hematology scenario
one of the most important lessons I want
to impart to you is that a lot of common
QC practices in hematology are
counterproductive they're wasteful
they're probably frustrating you and we
should abandon them and by knowing your
Sigma metric that'll help you figure out
how to readjust the way you're doing QC
that'll help reduce the number of
outliers reduce the number of repeats
and other bad practices that you're
doing also if you're using the
manufacturers range and the
manufacturers controlled those are going
to make it very difficult to do QC the
right way she use a manufacturer's SD
that's going to be big it's going to
lower your singer metrics which is going
to tell you to use more rules and run QC
more often whereas if you do your own SD
that will be smaller it'll give you the
more appropriate assessment of your
quality and you'll be able to use
hopefully fewer rules and fewer controls
so when we combine the Six Sigma
approach with the Westgard rules with
the QC frequency tools we can make sure
we're doing the right QC with the right
controls at the right frequency and all
of that is helping us support
the right patient care and the right
results of going to the patient and with
that I want to thank you for listening
in for accommodating me and looking at
these different tools and now I would
like to open this up to your questions
and if you are shy I also want you to
see at the bottom of this particular
slide my boss mandates that I put my
email address at the end of every
presentation so you have another way to
send me questions or any complaints or
comments as well and again thank you and
I look forward to hearing your questions
now
Thank You Sten for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar now if you
have a question you would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and we will answer as
many questions as we have time for okay
Stan let's get started let's start with
this question what is DPM
okay that's a great question Christy and
let me just pull up the slide that's
most relevant when we talk about Six
Sigma there's a one two three four five
six sigma but underneath each category
of Sigma is a number of defects per
million so Six Sigma works on a scale of
a million opportunities
so you run a process a million times you
report you run a million different
patient samples how many of those are
going to have defective results or false
positives or false negatives and the DPM
defects per million is what equates the
number of defects to the signal level at
Six Sigma
less than four defects per million so
the DPM is three point four actually and
then at three sigma it's about 67,000
defects per million sometimes you'll
also hear it called DPM o which is
defects per million opportunities
Thank You Sten now we have some great
questions coming in and I know we're
coming up at the top of the hour so
we're going to try to fit as many
questions in as we can
let's go with our next question we have
Abbott analyzers Selden rubies and we
use controls provided for Abbott but
these controls are manufactured for
strek do you consider this controls as a
third-party control that's a good
question and it brings to mind the
difference between a bundled control and
manufacturers control so as we noted
earlier the guidelines and the
regulations are encouraging labs to use
independent or third party controls
manufacturers control the the control
itself has been somehow
affected by the manufacturer itself
whereas a control that is independent
the manufacturer hasn't had a chance to
make any adjustments so if you're using
stretch controls and they're bundled
with your instrument whatever instrument
that happens to be that should maintain
its independence they're just bundled
together they're not actually aligned by
the manufacturer and of course the again
just to reiterate the the reason
manufacturer controls are not encouraged
is there's been too much evidence that
the manufacturer will try to widen the
ranges or they'll adjust the mean or in
some ways they're going to manipulate
how the control is run so that the lab
is not able to detect all the errors
that are occurring
and in a single CBC run there are
several parameters what if Sigma varies
per parameter and how should we
collectively rank Sigma in a single CBC
another great question I think if
anything you get out of today's
presentation is there is a high degree
of variability not only from instrument
to instrument but from test to test on
the Sigma metric and it's particularly
challenging for Hematology because you
make all the same measurements at the
same time but you will find for some
counts for some parameters for some
indexes the Sigma is not the same so
across and basically any instrument
there is no 1 Sigma or I should say
there's no single Sigma metric that
covers the whole instrument or all the
different tests so you will have some
areas where the parameters are at Six
Sigma and other parameters are at pre
Sigma and that does mean there's a
challenge about what the rules you're
going to apply how many controls you're
going to run and even now that we have
the TC frequency guidance how often
you're going to run QC and
of course it's impossible to change the
the frequency of QC on an index you
can't be running on your haemoglobin
you're running once per thousand but
then on your MCV you're running once per
500
you can't vary the number of controls
that way so effectively you have to come
up with a compromise that covers all of
the different parameters you might
decide I'm going to run your QC and set
your rules just based on the worst case
scenario or you might decide maybe I'll
do it on the best case scenario or
somewhere in the middle or what what we
encourage is define what are the
critical decision levels what's the
medical decision level where diagnoses
are being made or patient outcomes are
our most impactful and fix your Sigma
around that and then also you know I
would say you you're going to go with a
majority sense of do I have most of my
assays at Six Sigma I have a couple
assays at for a couple n3 maybe I have
one parameter that's below 2 Sigma I'm
probably going to design for the
majority of the assays and then for that
the ones that are in the minority if I
have one or two assays that are not very
good I'll try and take additional
actions for them they may they may be it
something that I do in addition to
Mystikal QC so that I might use more
rules but I might not be able to afford
to run more controls or to run those
controls more frequently and on the
outside of statistical QC perhaps using
the monitoring of patient values I'm
going to be doing more scrutiny of those
particular parameters
Thank You Sten now let's come over to a
question from Tyler can the lab use a
different Westgard multi rule definition
for example as 3 1 s or 3 2 1 s as a 1
rule instead of a systematic error run
reject rule
well that's a good question and let's
back up and just acknowledge that while
everyone believes there's one set of
Westgard rules in the 1981 paper made a
particular set of rules famous and many
people take that as a standard that is
not carved in stone the Westgard multi
rule approach is meant to be flexible so
there are combinations that are good for
when you're running two levels of
control there are combinations that are
more appropriate when you're running
three levels of control and then one of
the points of this presentation was to
use the Sigma to help you limit and
reduce the number of r-squared rules
that you're using so there's a lot of
flexibility that is inherent in how
you're supposed to use Westgard rules
and Sigma metrics now using the 1/3 rule
or the three 1s as a warning rule that's
perfectly acceptable you can take any
rule that you want and turn it into a
warning rule most of what our Sigma
metrics are doing for us are telling us
what rules are must be the rejection
rules and then any other rule beyond
that if you want to turn it into a
warning rule that's perfectly fine and
use your professional judgment if you
want to see that and and be alerted to
it that's fine okay because a warning
rule is not a rejection and for most of
your warnings you're going to end up
clearing it anyways so that's whether
you turn a rule into a warning rules is
really more about your own time
management we just want to make sure
you're not picking warning rules that go
off so often that they're really just a
distraction
thank you son now yet this question has
a few parts from a pragmatic point of
view how do we determine QC frequency
when the QC material covers all
reportable x' there is a variable range
of quality in each channel which means a
decision is needed do we set QC
frequency to the bad based on number
Channel or a stable RBC channel with the
wide range of total error for something
like the monos does it really matter
that's great I think that is the the new
challenge you know that now that we have
the science of determining QC frequency
now we have to match the mathematics
that we can get perky sufficiency with
the practical reality of how tests are
run and certainly for something like the
monocytes and the bat of as open channel
of the quality and some of the
differential accounts for a lot of
different manufacturers is not as high
as what you'd see on the RDC Channel so
this is new and actually this is I
suppose it's an opportunity for labs to
really apply and publish their results
because science is only about three
years old and we're we're still trying
to find laboratories to implement this
and see what they find is the most
useful the most practical the most
effective way to implement these QC
frequency policies so it's one area
where I agree that there's a challenge
and I think a mask provides us with one
answer but the more interesting answer
is going to come in the field from
laboratories like yourself to see what
what ends up being the best combination
or the best
census of the different capabilities of
the assay
Thank You Sten and thank you max for
that question it's coming to come over
to a question from Christian can we use
the manufacturer control just to obtain
our CD and SD and an external control to
obtain our bias
it's an interesting question typically
well looks when we talk about how we
have changed CV and bias we typically
have obtained that through two different
sources so we would be running some kind
of controls to determine our imprecision
and then we have some kind of external
quality assessment or proficiency
testing that may help us determine our
bias but if we were going to be using a
control to determine our bias so for
instance we have a control and they have
the peer group mean or the labeled mean
if I was going to be using the meet that
that to determine my bias I would also
want to use the imprecision from that
control in any assessment of Sigma
metric I would want to use the
imprecision of the manufacturer control
and then the bias of a third-party
control that come up with a signal
metric I I feel like again the
manufacturers control may be over
optimized so that imprecision will come
in being a little too low the
imprecision from the external control or
let's mission called the external
control the imprecision coming from the
third party or the independent control
that's considered a best practice as a
way to determine your your real
imprecision
Thank You Sten now I know we're getting
close to time but let's try to squeeze
in a few more let's go here we go many
sights I assist received one hematology
sample per month or twelve per year for
their equ apt program what
recommendations you have to best utilize
this external QC approach which can
complement their internal QC management
program
all right so what we would probably want
to do in this case is use multiple
samples and over multiple months to
determine the bias we wouldn't want to
peg too much importance on just the one
single once per month measurement if we
would calculate something like a
confidence interval around that we would
not be very happy but as we get a new
data point if we merge that information
with the previous three six or twelve
samples that came in over the past year
we could get a little more confident
about what is the bias that we're seeing
so we could get the individual bias
percentages and average them all
together maybe that's not the most ideal
ways to determine your bias but it it is
giving you a long-term assessment and an
overall assessment of the bias that
you're you're mentioning
that you're trying to determine
you stand now how often do we have to
measure our Six Sigma measuring Six
Sigma we find when we sample when we
actually talked with labs that do Six
Sigma they're looking maybe at once
every three months or once a month and
the only reason that they're doing it
once a month that frequently is
typically most labs are doing a QC
review at the end of the month and at
the same time you're doing a QC review
you have all the same information that
is going to feed into your Sigma metric
so if you're looking at the QC events
you have the data you can also look at
an update of the Sigma metric I do want
to calm everyone just because you're
looking at a Sigma metric every month
doesn't mean that any change will cause
you to change how you're doing QC or how
often you're going to run QC and I we
have examples on the website where lads
have been running instruments for eight
nine years and monitoring Six Sigma
metrics for that entire period and for
some tests they haven't changed their
Sigma metric effectively for that whole
period that is it was Six Sigma nine
years ago
it's Six Sigma today it's been six sigma
throughout those nine years it may have
fluctuated slightly but it stayed above
Six Sigma and that meant that there were
no QC modifications that had to be made
for that entire period
okay let's go with this next question
what is the laboratory to do when they
have tests for example total co2 with
terrible Sigma metric performance there
isn't an option to change chemistry
instruments so what is allowed to do
great question and that is a challenge
that labs face in chemistry they can
face it in hematology they can face it
just about anywhere there are there are
no perfect instruments there there's
always the possibility you're going to
get a bad particular a bad assay on a
big menu I will say specifically to co2
that is a challenge of an app assay it's
very hard for an automated instrument to
get a good co2 method and typically what
we recommend is sometimes you can look
at you know if it's an open system you
can see if you'd get a different reagent
and approve the performance but if you
let's take the broader idea of I have an
assay it's not great what am I going to
do with that
if switching is not an option if you've
tried ways to improve the imprecision
you've tried ways to reduce the bias and
you still have a low signal metric then
one of the things you can do is employ
what's called a reference change value
our our CV sometimes it's called a
critical difference the most the person
who has popularized it the most was
Callum Fraser you can find a lot of
details about this on our website and in
the scientific literature but
essentially it helps you adjust the
clinicians expectations about how to
handle those results so if you have a
low performing assay you'll be telling
the clinician you need to wait for a big
change before you think something has
happened with the patient you can
actually flag between cereal results you
can say the difference between the last
results on this patient and this result
is not big enough for you to think
there's a clinical change it's just
noise it's just the difference from day
to day so don't make a medical decision
on that particular result so we can sort
of couch each result in the context of
its quality for a Six Sigma say when you
report that out you can let the
clinician know if there's a change here
and it looks like it's a clinically
significant we're very confident
I'm going to be wrong about that less
than four times out of a million
reportable results so if you see a
change it's probably a change in the
patient a lo Sigma you start cautioning
the clinician don't make a decision yet
let the change get bigger do more
monitoring
now Stan is it correct that these
general principles that you've described
this morning also apply to general
chemistry and immunoassays
um yeah obviously the Westgard rules are
most well known and applied in chemistry
we have if you look at our website a
majority of the examples that we show
are on chemistry but if it has a
quantitative result then that test can
probably be applied with signal metrics
so the single metric equation itself
doesn't care if it's from chemistry or
immunoassay or co AG or infectious
disease or hematology as long as those
numbers are coming in they have the
right distribution we can apply signal
metrics there's a little bit of
individual details for each kind of test
you know hematology is different because
of the short shelf life of hematology
controls and some of the indexes but
there are adjustments that we can make
on how we apply signal metrics in those
scenarios
then now we've have so many great
questions coming in we could be talking
and answering questions for at least
another hour so but let's go ahead and
wrap with this final question I just
want to do remind all of our audience
members that those questions that you
did submit today that we don't have time
to answer and all those questions that
you are available able to submit during
the on-demand period they will be
addressed via the email address you
provided at the time of registration so
then let's go with this one final
question how should my QC approach
change with the recent waved
instrumentation for CDC for example full
blood count and that FPC analysis soon
to be on the IV deed market okay and
just before I answer that question I
will say I at West guard at the West
guard websites will try and put together
as many of the questions that have been
submitted and put answers to them and so
not only will we possibly respond to
your email but we'll try and put
something online on one of our websites
that is accessible for everyone so look
look for forthcoming Q&A set article on
the West guard websites now getting back
to the specific question there's a
regulatory answer to this question and
then there is a best practice yeah
answer to this question so with waived
instruments on theoretically the FDA has
made a determination that no harm can
come from the use of these results and
therefore the only thing that the user
has to do is follow the manufacturers
directions and the manufacturer may just
say put your limits out at this set you
know put your limits here X&Y and run
control on three controls and three
external controls maybe once a week once
a month or something like that
and you will be in compliance but
you may not be doing best practice at
all so I regardless of the status of the
instrument whether it's waived non ways
whether it's moderately or high complex
we encourage the same best practice
which is determine your own standard
deviation determine your own mean try
and do some regular or checking against
some external source you want to do
proficiency testing and external quality
assessment use that imprecision use that
bias to help you determine a signal
metric if it turns out yes I have a Six
Sigma method and it tells me I could
reduce my QC frequency to once per
several thousand patient results if that
happens to go along with the
manufacturers recommendations that's
great if you turn turns out you have an
instrument that's waived but the Sigma
metrics are really really low I would
follow the cigarette ryx and say I need
to do more Westgard rules I need to run
more controls than what the manufacturer
is recommending because it's better to
be helping your patients with the
appropriate level of quality than just
maintaining the compliance and surviving
an inspection
with that I do want to again thank you
all for attending thank you for
submitting such good questions stay
tuned for the answers to those questions
and stay tuned bit because there will be
more articles about hematology QC coming
coming forth in the next year
Thank You Stan and would you remind our
audience what that website is oh sorry
it's a Westgard com and of course my own
email address is West guard at West
guard calm excellent thank you again
Stan for your time today and for your
important contribution to laboratory
quality control we'd also like to thank
lab Rhodes and our sponsor Abbott
Laboratories for underwriting today's
educational webcast one last thank you
to our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions again
those questions we were not able to
answer today in any of those that are
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration and as Dan mentioned you
will be doing a little QA listing on his
website and that website is Westgard
calm now this webcast can be viewed
on-demand and laberd's will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day